in this technique mike's coming in to
hit me on the side of the head
boom as i see him raise to hit me i'm
right on the ball and i enter in
knocking him back
but i don't quite finish him off so when
i come in he's still sticking around
i'm going to come to this game and
control it if you had a weapon hand if
you had a weapon in this hand would be
very important to make sure that you
can't do any more damage with it
so right after this position i'm going
to come in here and grab his wrist now
when i grab i'm grabbing with the palm
of my hand towards the back of mike's
hand here
this hand that was controlling the elbow
slides to his elbow and i apply the
gokyo here as mike goes lower
i'm going to drive down into the gokyo
driving his shoulder into the mat
from this tokyo position after mike
gives me the tap there we're going to
simulate someone pulling their arm in
so i ride this down put it against the
mat and again apply goku
one more time at speed
yoko mnuchi gokyo